my good buddy NFL Network analyst
compadre former Jaguar Raider current
radio analyst for your defending NFC
champion Los Angeles Rams Maurice
jones-drew how REM JD how are you I'm
doing fine I know it took a couple of
cracks for you to answer your phone
D are you one of those types that don't
answer call numbers that you don't have
in your phone or you those types MJ well
Richie told me it was a 3-1 know number
so I was looking for a 3-1 oh and I
wanted to make sure that I wasn't on the
phone when you call so the answer is yes
the answer is yes you do not answer
phone calls that do not show up on your
phone as somebody that you have in your
phone is that a Churchill is that true
it's tough to get through those those
pearly gates of the Maurice jones-drew
phone book really is something else man
you know I like it
everything good with you everything you
know I heard you talking about en
rapport now chef is that right I'm off
well this you 10 of my offseason so I
get a little time off which is nice I
hang out with the kids and do some other
adventures that I have going on back
home and tell everyone how I caught you
yesterday we were you reading when I
picked on yes I was a I'm the president
of a youth football organization so we
had a board meeting yesterday when we
were talking I was on my way there it
was fun I had some it has some really
good things trying to try to keep it up
I love it
all right I'm JD let's get to the meat
and potatoes here you're kind of my
levian bell Westberg not only are you
guy who knows him you share an agent
you're also running back of note
yourself what's going through his mind
today when there's all these reports
conjecture tweets rumor that's been
confirmed sources say all that business
that his new coach didn't want to have
the salary handed to him that the
general manager that he obviously won in
a power struggle with handed levy on how
is he taking that news do you think
today well I think he went to Twitter
and Instagram yesterday to talk about it
and from what I can gather he was you
know it's the same he has more to prove
then and he's not really worried about
what people think about him how much
he's getting paid he wants to go out to
show that he's
the best running back in the league and
you know there's been a lot of grief of
him not being at voluntary workouts and
those type of things but we've seen
other players get hurt at those workouts
and you know it again it's you have to
preserve your body because what's most
important is what you get to fall camp
being in the best shape of your life
going to mini camp which is mandatory
and doing the things there show that you
you're in top shape there then making it
through the season the seasons a
marathon a lot of people don't really
understand that because you know
basketball you may have a seven game
series and those type of things we all
know in football it's one game you have
to be able to be at your best for 16 of
those and possibly three more at the end
and so he's taking the proper
precautions to do that and so when I
asked him about what Adam Gatien and
talked to our agent about it I mean it's
just kind of like waters off a duck's
back to him you know he was like if I go
out there night produce and I do what I
did in Pittsburgh and help win games for
the New York Jets and then it all go
away
but right now there's not a lot of news
going around and you know obviously with
the firemen mckagan and all the reports
come around he was like it is what it is
I'm gonna keep on what I I feel like I
can do what I can produce and be ready
to go out and play so you don't think
Adam GaSe needs to call him and
basically say what what he really felt
or and confirm what's in the paper or or
saying nothing like literally like just
like let's move on and and and that that
one strikes me is there needs to be some
form of a conversation in Levien's
direction don't you think maurice i
think there will be when he comes back
you know it's funny race when I heard
that report and I was reading it I heard
actually the total opposite coming out
of this last season that of Adam GaSe
and his staff the front office was still
thin in Miami that they were gonna break
the bank for ladyís bill to come down to
Miami and keep him there that was from
people in the building that was from
people reporters that are that you know
their daily reporters with the Dolphins
there was a ton of people saying that
they are ready to break the bank only
made sense without a case went to the
Jets that Ozzie lady on bill goes there
and so you know there's always everyone
has a high sighs - everyone I call it
but I think sometimes we're trying to as
coaches we always see that they always
try to protect themselves cover cover
their butt and say well you know I
didn't want to give him that much well
you know for what I heard that he was
willing to give him more in Miami if he
was still in Miami so I don't know how
these reports get out or how their
leader whatever it may be you know as
long as the Jets win that's the most
important thing they put together a
great foundation - free agent pieces
they did had a really good draft and so
now it's all on the coach to get all
this talent that they've acquired over
the last year in the last couple drafts
with Sam Donald and other players to go
out there and win and so I think that's
what's most important if you don't call
them it's a little bit different than
the roses situation because these are
just reports that are coming I don't
have to call me overlap or so ever going
to trade me I would like to you to you
know to get a phone call which I heard
Kliff Kingsbury did and obviously Steve
time didn't but you know that's a
different scenario well let's put a pin
in that for a second because I want to
hit that with you since you brought it
up in a second I just like I I put
myself on other people's shoes that's
that's what I always try to do and then
try to put the listener and viewer in
those shoes from my perspective Maurice
if let's just say I'm fighting for what
I think is a good salary for my hosting
abilities let's just say with the NFL
Network right and and the guy who
finally gives me what I think is worth
or what I'm worth or close to what I
think I am worth gives me that deal and
then all of a sudden the other person
who is is part and parcel of the
production side of things at the NFL
Network wins a power struggle within the
building and is now the one in charge
and the one who gave me the money is now
gone and I find out that the one who's
now in charge didn't want to pay me what
I thought I was worth I would be so
pissed now I'd be I'd do the best job I
possibly can because I'm a professional
but that would be in the back of my mind
every single time
that person sat down and go over a
rundown with me or my schedule I would
never ever forget it
period yeah I don't think lady I'm bills
not gonna fry thing he's you know he's
going to kind of tuck that away along
with a couple other things that have
been said about him throughout this this
year off of football and he's gonna use
that his motivational always training I
I don't know if our listeners follow him
on Instagram and then Twitter but they
should because every time I look up he's
always working out he's always putting
his best foot forward and he looks
really good he looks like he's you know
come back to his playing weight and so
III expected things I'm I think you'll
see when he's carrying the ball it's so
funny I tell people this all the time
running backs are devalued until you
need him in the fourth quarter when the
game you want to give us the ball
fifteen times like lawyers run it's like
lawyers it's so funny and it's like all
he's not worth this but then when the
game for the line you got to run out the
clock that you need a guy back there
that can do it you're gonna do it and so
I think maybe on understand that but
please let's not forget like he is human
he does understand like those things
that are being said he's gonna harness
those things and he'll use those of when
the time is necessary and in Kurt Warner
tweeting out yesterday as well saying
that some coaches think that the players
aren't worth the money but they love
coaching them and that they separate the
business from the football acumen and
that may be what Adam GaSe is doing I
don't know what we'll do see how it all
plays out but all I know is the first
time that levy on bail is required to
show up for work and does stand in front
of a microphone that will and that's
gonna be his welcome to the New York
media market oh my god I mean seriously
this is you're not in western
Pennsylvania or East Lansing Michigan
anymore I'm serious you know this is
this is serious business here now the
funny thing about it is and I think a
lot of people don't understand is that
lazy on like part of going to adjust yet
other offers that were pretty strong
late and I think it but it wasn't the
enticing at the city of New York and
being able to play in front of you know
in the one that is not the biggest media
market in the world and having that type
of pressure put on he thrives with those
type of
so he was excited to be there that's one
of the reasons why he chose the Jets in
that free agency race that they have to
walk Maurice jones-drew here on the Rich
Eisen show okay
you mentioned fellow Bruin Josh Rosen
and his appearance here on this show on
Monday where I asked him to describe you
know his feelings now that he's removed
from the raw emotions of what happened
in Arizona and he told us a story about
how his former general manager is
referred to Steve calm never called him
and you've just made mention of it just
moments ago does that surprise you is
that what it is that what you would
expect a general manager to reach out to
a player you would think so um you know
I think sometimes general manners try to
remove themselves from the business of
like being personally connected with
players but we as players understand
going into this that you know you're
gonna get cut you're gonna get you have
a chance of being traded just treat me
like a human being and not a piece of
meat and not a package or not something
that you just don't have to talk to I
think Josh did a really good job of
expressing that it Kliff Kingsbury did
it is brand-new today and I fell and I
get seen time has a lot to do but what
did the text say list Josh sorry I
didn't work out you know I wish you the
best of luck in Miami that takes two
seconds to do that or send a text
something but to act as if he doesn't
exist and he doesn't help you is beyond
me so I think so many times you know GM
in our in our business try to try to
remove themselves like well I don't want
to get attached to a player because
it'll be hard to release them that's
part of the business I remember when I
first got the Jacksonville Shaq Harris
you know I think one of the better teams
in this league has been in this league
told us in the very the first meeting my
job is to find a better version of you
hmm so and so I'm gonna keep you as long
as I can find a better version of you
what does the component what is honest
if you're honest and I know if I'm going
out and I'm not doing my job you're
gonna find a better version of me
when you try to like not show that
emotion not treat me like a person or
just just not even act as if what you
did you know you you can do whatever you
want right it is your team you do
whatever you want at least give me the
common courtesy to say hey I sorry
things didn't work out I wish you the
best of luck
how did the kid who wore number 32
because that was the number of teams
that picked on you passing you up on the
first round out how did that kid take
that and we in real-time with Jack
Harris that's a hue City right it was so
for me it was like I mean I'm in a
business in FL this is what it is and so
I I made sure that every day I went out
to practice I kept that in the back of
my mind I gave it my all every day we
play in every game I play I gave it
everything I had
and until honestly my time was up in
Jackson when I went to Oakland for a
year and didn't and and I I tried to be
the best player that I could be so that
I could again you're always you know I
think our fans understand every day you
step with the building you're being
evaluated and so you may walk wrong you
may talk to the wrong person the wrong
way all those things are being evaluated
so you have to you know make sure that
you are at your best every day and it's
tough to do and so that's why I've never
really you know like when people are
talking about Lady I'm not showing up to
voluntary workouts or Tom Brady and
Gronk didn't do it last year to me you
got to be at your best when your best is
needed and if or if you're either
training at the facility you're not
training at the team facility help you
get to be your best you got to do what's
best for you because that didn't end as
we're being evaluated on it so I would
just hope that in the future if it's
Steve time or any other GM have the
common decency just to tell the player
you don't have to look me and my like
just just tell me you know it's gonna be
okay like I wish you the best of luck
going forward you know it just didn't
work out here I don't think is that hard
to do those type of things
when you you know drop the guy top ten
and then you come back the next year and
drop the guy number one
he knows he's probably not going to be
there but to act as if he doesn't it's
just
it just I don't know it don't know how
to explain that a few more minutes left
with Maurice jones-drew here on the Rich
Eisen show I know how the fan base
reacts when there's news of some motive
Patrick Peterson's caliber as Adam
Schefter reported dropping an appeal of
a suspension for PE D violation a policy
violation he's gonna get six games
according to Adam handed down shortly
how does the player community react to
news of somebody of Patrick's caliber
it's always tough to see that you know
you wish him the best when he comes back
and and whatever happened like we don't
just never know what was posited in
those situations but you know it sucks
because he's such a great player
and he's done he'd done so well for so
long for that organization now it's kind
of like a [ __ ] in the armor but
hopefully he can come back better and
and go out there and make plays and and
get back to the guy that we saw the
field the last how many ever years he's
been in the league I don't think his
play has ever dropped off and then the
Rams sir in that division
now that Murray's in there that's gonna
be so much fun I mean this division just
gets tougher and tougher tougher and
obviously Jimmy G is coming back we know
what Seattle's moves are they've paid
Russell Wilson
it looks like the Rams - Sioux right I'm
kind of go off the top of my head here
yeah it looks like they're just gonna
run it back
add they add the the draft picks
they added Weddell who I love Clay
Matthews who's gonna have you want to
talk about chip on his shoulder in
Southern California and cup comes back
what are your thoughts on the team that
you call and you know so much about and
well I think again you know when they
they really did a great job building
foundational pieces last year throughout
free agency getting the key to leave
Marcus Peters obviously via trade you
had sue and but now you go now you're
able to draft some guys I can come and
play those positions they took us D
tackle out of Washington undersized kid
but he's tough versus a run and he's
gonna be able to take it those double
team something that suits really didn't
excel that's a play off so I think the
you know that you're you're adding
Thousand Cup coming back will be huge
you've added another running back a
couple more often sublime they've done a
really good job of sticking to their
plan as other teams have gotten better
obviously Seattle pays Russell Wilson
Bishop the highest-paid they go add a
couple receivers of the draft they've
done a great job it'll be a tough
division the one seam that I've always
been concerned about really in the girls
with the Cardinals is Josh Rosen was
fact so many times last year and yet
they really didn't address that
offensive line the way that I thought
they would now grant they're gonna get
some guys back because of injuries and
things like that but you don't want a
young quarterback like Kyler Murray she
start running early in his career
because once you take off and start
running early in your career that's what
you're going to get used to and
accustomed to and you'll do that
throughout your career
yes he can do and he's a tremendous
talent would you have to make sure that
he can win from the pocket I it's so fun
I had to talk with Charlie Castillo one
of our colleagues that I've gone Network
and he always harps on you have to win
from the pocket you can be able to run
and have that dynamic but if you can't
win from the pocket it tough to win in
this league and that's really true
because as offensive linemen they have
to know where you're going to be at all
times so that they can protect you and
like block at certain angles so it's
complications to see how they do really
excited to see what the Niners do I
think the Niners are closer than what
people think but we'll see how Jimmy G
is it all relies on Jimmy G he got paid
a lot of money right and there's a high
expectation for him he got hurt last
year so how could he come back they've
added some really good pieces and
throughout the draft and free agency to
help that defense that often so I'm
excited to see it'll be exciting offers
I know I'll see you at the Coliseum a
couple times oh yeah
so when that happens it's gonna be uh go
be some fireworks out they're gonna be
great it's gonna be great mjd you're
great thanks for calling and appreciate
it enjoy time with your family kids and
youth football enjoy that's Maurice
jones-drew at mjt love that guy for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app